ein neuer meilenstein gelangen jetzt
eine us forschungsteam sie haben
quantenbits als licht partikel durch
eine rund 40 kilometer lange
glasfaserleitung geschickt und das mit
einer genauigkeit von 90 das ist
revolutionär denn das quanten internet
wäre abhörsicher und sicher vortag
manipulation und diebstahl gerade sind
die usa einem riesigen hacker angriff
zum opfer gefallen
zahlreiche amerikanische ministerien
wurden erfolgreich angegriffen könnte
das damit verhindert werden mit den
quanten internet-klicks 15 user gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los haben sich gebraucht so gibt es
übrigens inzwischen auch als erfolgreich
und wissenschafts podcast also wer keine
augen für zum hat weil er zum beispiel
unterwegs ist sondern nur ohren am
besten hier auf sie klicken dann kommt
er direkt zum podcast der traum vieler
fachleute weltweit das quanten internet
das perfekt abhörsichere nachrichten
versenden kann
und es sind bei weitem nicht nur
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die dieses visionäre internet herbei
sind sondern natürlich auch regierung
und das militär die ein großes interesse
daran haben alle informationen 100% sich
abzusichern aber auch unternehmen wie
banken oder versicherungen wollen ihre
verträge und transaktionen geheim halten
dazu kommt möglicherweise sind die
ersten quantencomputer schon in naher
zukunft in der lage die verschlüsselung
die derzeit noch verwendet werden zu
knacken
das quanten internet könnte hier abhilfe
schaffen doch nicht nur das fanden
computer könnten viele weitere komplexe
probleme lösen in der
medikamentenforschung für berechnungen
in der logistik der finanzwirtschaft bei
künstlicher intelligenz oder
datensicherheit ein quanten internet
also ein netzwerk über das gespeicherte
informationen über große entfernungen
ausgetauscht werden könnte sogar eine
neue ära der kommunikation bleiben ein
wichtiger schritt hin zu einem
funktionsfähigen quanten internet ist
jetzt ein us forscherteam gelungen
und nicht nur die entfernung die hierbei
überwunden werden konnte ist beeindruckt
sondern auch die erreichte
datengenauigkeit und es gibt einen
weiteren punkt der das neue
forschungsergebnisse nicht nur absolut
spektakulär macht sondern
ist auch schon heute praxistauglich
macht von anfang an fanden computer als
parallele des quanten internet sind
jedenfalls in der lage berechnung
millionenfach schneller zu erledigen als
es normale pcs können möglich wird das
durch fanden physikalische phänomene der
so genannten quanten bits abgekürzt
kubis das sind einzelne teilchen wie
photonen oder elektronen oder oder oder
quantencomputer können dank dieser cubes
und deren quantenphysikalische phänomene
eine aufgabe sehr sehr viel schneller
bearbeiten
denn das cupid kann anders als es in der
klassischen digitaltechnik möglich ist
mit mehr als zwei zuständen operieren
und das gleichzeitig es gibt nicht nur
die 1 und die null wie sibitz in unseren
heutigen computer und haben jetzt können
sie in beiden positionen gleichzeitig
befinden und zudem auch theoretisch
unendlich viele zustände dazwischen
annehmen damit wächst die speicherbare
datenmenge mit jedem weiteren coup
exponentiell an vereinfacht ausgedrückt
rechnet xy gleichzeit können unsere
heutigen computer ein ergebnis ausgeben
cupid kann
zwei ergebnisse ausgeben 243 8 416 5 32
664 7 128 8 256 9 512 10.000 24 11 2008
und 40 12 4096 13 8192 14 16 1384 und
bei 64 sind es 18,46 trillionen eine
absolut unglaubliche zahl
und sie sehen verschenkt macht ein
teilchen etwas tut es das verschränkte
teilchen auch unser zeitgleich spricht
das geschieht schneller als wenn die
teilchen mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
kommunizieren wird für die praxis
bedeutet das mögliche lösungen können
parallel durchgespielt und berechnet
werden in der theorie ist klar dass
quantencomputer somit in der zukunft
selbst den stärksten supercomputer
überhaupt überlegen sein werden und auf
den gleichen technischen grundlagen
entsteht dann auch das quanten internet
das die ganze welt umspannt abhörsicher
wird die kommunikation darüber weil
teilchen quasi gebiet werden denn das
ist die auswirkungen der verschränkung
das wird möglich durch die zitat
spukhafte verschränkung von teilchen wie
albert einstein ist
damals bezeichnete erhielt das ganze
wirklich für unmöglich aber wir wissen
heute es ist nicht nur möglich und
realität sondern wir können es auch
anwenden zwei teilchen die genau
denselben quantenzustand haben werden zu
diesem zweck erzeugt diese teilchen sind
verschränkt und bleiben auch miteinander
verbunden wenn man sie kennt denn egal
wie weit sie voneinander entfernt sind
bleiben ihre zustände sind chrome der
vorteil es ist unmöglich informationen
abzuhören oder abzufangen
denn sobald der zustand eines teilchens
gemessen wird verlässt es den zustand
der super position in dem es mehrere
zustände gleichzeitig hat und nimmt
einen einzigen zustand an sprich wird
die kommunikation ab gehört also
gemessen merkt dass der empfänger sofort
alles etwas schwierig vorzustellen denn
diese logik der quantenphysik
widerspricht einfach allem was wir
menschen selbst im alltag erfahren doch
fest steht es funktioniert und wir haben
dieses absolut mysteriöse verhalten in
die wirklichkeit geholt und wenden es an
das hat china schon vor einigen jahren
bewiesen mit einem quanten netzwerk seit
ende 2012 erfahren die westlichen
geheimdienste nichts mehr darüber was
bei dem parteikongressen entschieden
wurde
die chinesen hatten ein quanten netzwerk
installiert und die kommunikation über
eine leitung verschränkt absolut
abhörsicher doch dogs intensiver
forschung gibt es noch zwei große
herausforderungen zu lösen zum einen die
übertragung über große entfernungen
hinweg und zum anderen die
datengenauigkeit so muss also dringend
vermieden werden dass die lichtteilchen
unterwegs verloren gehen doch das ist
alles andere als einfach denn selbst
glas ohne verunreinigung absorbiert
diese photonen also die lichtteilchen
bei den klassischen übertragungen mit
hilfe von biz ist das keineswegs ein
problem der nähe werden ganze
lichtbündel über die leitungen geschickt
zudem sorgen hier kontroll bis dafür
dass die informationen trotzdem ankommt
doch das soll auch das quanten internet
nicht länger aufhalten und so tüfteln
fachleute weltweit an diesen
herausforderungen eine erfolgsmeldung
kommt jetzt eben aus den usa den
forschenden ist es gelungen quantenbits
als licht partikel durch eine 44
kilometer lange glasfaserleitung zu
schicken aber nicht die entfernung
allein ist sehr beeindruckend sondern
auch die datengenauigkeit für 90 prozent
und das ist neuer rekord denn auch wenn
diese distanz in der vergangenheit
bereits überwunden werden konnte gelang
ist
nicht mit einer solchen genauigkeit so
wurden cubes beispielsweise bereits über
eine strecke von 100 kilometern
geschickt doch hierbei konnte lediglich
eine genauigkeit von 85 prozent erreicht
werden hinzu kommt und das ist wirklich
der bahn brechen das aktuelle experiment
des forschungsteams lässt sich mit
dieser genauigkeit wiederholen und sogar
verbessern und ein weiteres highlight
die fachleute hatten lediglich hardware
genutzt die zitat in serie gefertigt
wird und auf einer telekommunikations
infrastruktur basiert die ist bereits
gibt dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
das projekt schafft eine basis für einen
hochleistungspumpen internet mit
gewöhnlichen geräten überhaupt der
us-physiker panagiotis spenden zu riss
war an der studie beteiligt und sagt wir
sind begeistert von diesen ergebnissen
dies ist eine wichtige errungenschaft
auf dem weg zum aufbau einer technologie
die unsere globale kommunikation neu
definiert auch andere fachleute die
nicht an der studie selbst beteiligt
waren sehen die forschungsergebnisse als
erfolg demnach sei die distanz von 44
kilometern absolut ausreichend um die
übertragung innerhalb einer großstadt zu
gewährleisten vor allem das gewöhnliche
glasfaserkabel genutzt wurden über die
auch heutzutage bereits die internet
übertragung läuft macht dieses projekt
zu überragend auf der webseite von
sunset heißt es das besondere an dieser
studie ist die genauigkeit und
entfernung sowie die verwendete
standardausrüstung theoretisch sollte es
relativ einfach sein diese technologie
mit der bereits vorhandenen hardware zu
skalieren
die us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wollen ihre ergebnisse
durch system upgrades noch im laufenden
jahr 2021 verbessern dazu die witzigeren
maria spiropoulos die an der studie
beteiligt war
wir sind sehr stolz darauf diesen
meilenstein für nachhaltige
leistungsstark und skalierbare quanten
teleportation systeme erreicht zu haben
haben wir damit also das zeitalter der
quantencomputer erreicht der stuttgarter
quantenphysiker zum kunden sieht das
skeptisch in einem spiegel -interview
schätzt der experte dass es noch etwa
zehn jahre dauern könnte bis
quantencomputer einsatzbereit sein um
eine oder mehrere einfache aber
nützliche aufgaben zu übernehmen
dazu kommt im spiegel-interview
empfanden computer so weit sind gehen
wir davon aus
das sind die vielen wichtigen probleme
lösen die die besten supercomputer der
welt nicht in millionen jahren aus
rechnen können dass die quantencomputer
den klassischen rechnern überlegen sind
hatte google vor zwei jahren 2009 10 mit
seinem fanden computer super moore
gezeigt dieser rechner basiert auf 53
supraleitenden cubis und hat den wenigen
minuten eine komplexe
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung gelöst
allerdings war die aufgabe so gewählt
dass sie ein quantencomputer eben lösen
konnte und zwar in 3 minuten und 20
sekunden und ein heutiger supercomputer
dafür 10.000 jahre gebraucht hätte
allerdings ein chinesischer fanden
simulator hatte erst ende des
vergangenen jahres 2020 eindeutig die
überlegenheit der quanten über die
klassischen rechner demonstriert er
hatte einen rechenarbeit von 2,5
milliarden jahren mit nummer 1 erhalten
2,5 milliarden jahren in achtung 2/100
sekunden gelöst konkret ging es um die
verteilung von photonen in der so
genannten personen probe diese aufgabe
gilt für supercomputer als nahezu
unlösbar und diese aufgabe hat praxis
dazu viele sehen dieses ergebnis eines
chinesischen forschungsteams als
eindeutigen beweis für die überlegenheit
der quanten dazu sagt der physiker
fahnen der an der studie beteiligt war
wir haben gezeigt dass der photonen die
fundamentalen grund einhalten des lichts
nutzen können um eine aufwand
übersehende rechenleistung zu
demonstrieren die ihre klassischen
gegenparts weit übertrifft
der entwickelte kanten simulator
brauchte 2 100 sekunden statt 2,5
milliarden jahren was uns wirklich
absolute wahnsinn
für den drittschnellsten supercomputer
der welt mit der bezeichnung light wäre
diese aufgabe aber weiterhin um lösbar
er würde nach ansicht der fachleute 2,5
milliarden jahre benötigen ein nachteil
hat dieses optische quantensystem
dennoch denn es handelt sich um einen
simulator das heißt also dass das system
nicht programmierbar ist und lediglich
für die lösung dieses problems
entwickelt wurde das ziel der fachleute
ist es jetzt natürlich das quantensystem
in einem programmierbaren quantenrechner
weiterzuentwickeln es bleibt also noch
viel zu tun aber die entwicklung geht
rasend voran und es scheint als hätten
wir dann ein wirklich sicheres internet
denn so kann s
weiter gehen inzwischen sind
kreditkarten informationen schon so oft
gehackt worden bei banken bei
dienstleistern und wenn man recherchiert
der wird schnell erfahren dass
zahlreiche seiner passwörter inzwischen
öffentlich sind kein wunder dass die
extremen gesicherten bitcoins immer
beliebter werden virtuelle währung
bitcoins & co auf dem prüfstand
anklicken anschauen und diesen kanal ihr
diesen kanal klicks umsatz im future
unbedingt abonnieren es lohnt sich wir
hoffentlich auch in diesem video gemerkt
habt bis dann bleib dran